في مستودع مهجور في العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس صور المخرج الايراني مهران تمد
فيلما يروي فيه ثلاثه اشخاص الاهوال
والفضاء التي شاهدوها في السجون الايرانيه
الفيلم الذي عرض في مهرجان برلين
السينمائي الدولي شرح فيه المعتقلون
الثلاثه في سرد مستفيض كيف عذبوا داخل
السجون الايرانيه احد المشاركين في الفيلم
يروي قصته ويصف كيف تم ربط قدميهم باسلاك
كهربائيه ادت الى تمزيق جلده واخضاعه
لوضعيه الحزمه التعذيبيه حيث يكب فيها
السجين على وجهه ارضا وتربه يداه في ساقيه
المقرفصتين
التعذيب في السجون الايرانيه لم يقتصر على
الرجال فاحدى السجينات تروي ما حدث لها
داخل سجون الملالي حيث تصف كيف كانت تتعرض
للضرب المخرج الايراني لم يكتفي بهذه
الروايات بل طلب من المعتقلين السابقين
استجوابه كما لو انهم من جهاز امن ايراني
ليظهر للعالم بشاعه العيش تحت ظل نظام
رجعي لا يعترف بحقوق الاخرين
عثمان عمر العربيه